we spent some time talking about this
with David Ortiz taking his final
curtain call Thursday at Yankee Stadium
we wondered who was more valuable to
their respective franchises Derek Jeter
or Big Papi and I think initially you
think Derek Jeter but the more you think
about it with what big Papi's done with
three World Series titles they wouldn't
have won those titles without him and
probably the most feared batter you
would think in the last 15 years is Big
Papi so we reached out to Curt Schilling
and his former teammate and he joins us
now Kurt could you be objective when you
look at that who's been more valuable to
their franchise Jeter Big Papi yeah but
let me just first off say bringing me
into with Rush in the background was
fired me up a little bit that was a
outstanding call producer good so you
you said you can or can't be auditioning
here's the thing that people don't
understand when you have to preface this
conversation with you know it's like
comparing you know Lou Gehrig Babe Ruth
when you talk about one being better
than the other one it's on the level of
Hall of Fame this right yes so you're
not saying the other one isn't valuable
it's just a different kind of value but
when you I think when you look at Derek
and his value to the Yankees so so a lot
of people don't understand and he was
good right he was really really good
this guy hit 310 over what a 20-year
career you know that that's that's way
beyond just being good you know my only
I guess you'd call it beef with with the
people that talk about their experience
I always thought he was a and again with
in Hall of Fame perspective never
thought he was an above an average
defender I think that that was part of
his game that was very overrated
I think the Gold Gloves were I think an
indicative of that but again you're
talking about being overrated on a very
good level but you know you look at his
career averages you know he was
averaging like fifteen and eighty over
his career you know home runs and RBIs
and he had I think almost 160 games in
the postseason and he hit 20 homers he
was a guy who stepped it up now that's
not every postseason but you look at
majority of his postseasons except for a
one when you know he had some issues
hitting the big lefty but he was clutch
but but I look at him as someone who
carried on the Yankee the Yankee thing
right I mean them winning it wasn't like
oh my god the Yankees won a World Series
it was ok here comes more of the same
and that's not a bad thing but I think
when you look at the court floor with
him and Posada you know and Rivera and
Pettit you know I think they were each
involved in that and then you switch
over to David and you know if you look
at David's postseason numbers David
didn't it didn't hit 300 in the
postseason but like you look at 2013 he
has I think two hits against Detroit and
the ALCS one was a Grand Slam then the
one that won the long series he was as
timely as any player I've ever played
with he I know it makes the Sabre
matricies mad but he was in my mind I
never saw anybody more clutch than him
but you have I think Derrick finished in
the top 10 and MVP like eight times in
his career which is impressive
David finished in the top five five
years in a row when you look at that run
from from oh three to 207 two World
Series
David was next to Manny and think about
that David and Manny back there back at
that time he was as clutch as they come
but David helped change the narrative
right I mean David comes here and he'll
the Red Sox her the lovable losers and
all the things to go with that and and
David steps on the stage you know three
and then promote for it and now he's
been no he's been would you have won the
World Series that first one without
Ortiz no no no no gosh no no and I think
many as well but if you look at the
first one in Oh for you remember the
Yankee series I mean back-to-back nights
it was a home run off of Quantrill and
the broken bat walk-off flies to the
next night you know and then the I don't
know if you remember get well I would
imagine you remember game 7 to some
degree of that series met you remember
Damon gets thrown out in the first
inning at home plate right on the
Ramirez single diamond then hits a
two-run home run
that was one of those kind of a hidden
key like oh my god when Damon got thrown
I don't play what they can all know
there's no way we got to seven games and
this is going to happen next - bet you
go hit the home run and it's like okay
we're fine and I'll tell you even better
than that was the night that that I
think it was Game four that we won
David Homer enough Tom gored in the
eighth inning which was the biggest run
in the game I'm all in my mind so they
were clutch moments for both of them and
I think that they meant everything you
could want them to mean to both
franchises in very different ways you
know what the thing is I don't know
Derek obviously as well as I know David
but I will tell you this every good
thing you ever want to think about a
person is true about David Ortiz he is
as genuine as they come he was you know
he played almost 20 years and how many
of those in Boston
what for almost 15 14 15 and he had his
spats with the media every now and then
but that's what a competitor does but he
was never it was never stupid in a
hall-of-famer
huh homeless a Marine oh absolutely
that's I think when he goes in Edgar
Martinez he's going with them but
absolutely I don't think there's any
question I think both of them are first
bellick so you think ortiz will open the
door well there's only Edgar Harold
Baines maybe as right guys who are DHS I
enter was all a favor to me it should be
much like Tim Raines I think Edgar
Martinez changed the designated hitter
from being the fat guy who couldn't play
first base to being an elite middle of
line of bat and and he was every bit
that and I think David just picked that
up a notch so do you but how much do you
factor in postseason performance to
regular season you know well I mean I do
the whole thing I don't know how they do
it what the voters do it but those are
here's the thing so so I just Jeter was
a 300 hitter in 158 games in the
postseason every one of those games was
against the best of the best right there
were no there were no san diego's or
or there were no minutes
is on the schedule you're playing the
best and often times you're in the
series where you're facing you know the
ace twice or three times so those
numbers are even better than they look
which is amazing to me i factor it in
because that to me speaks volumes about
the man what kind of competitor he is
what kind of person he is because I
always felt like in the postseason the
reason I could I thought I could be
better than everybody else because I can
always take a breath when no one else
could breathe
he's Curt Schilling joining us Dan
Patrick show Jeter hit 327 against you
18 for 55 yes yeah and listen I'm gonna
caveat yes he did before I lost my
velocity he was up like a sub 200 hitter
and then once I lost my fastball I could
not get him out he he got on me so bad
and so often that he became a problem
for me he had to Homer do you remember
the two home runs he hit oh yeah yeah
yeah one in Philadelphia to right field
and this the year after so they came to
Philly in 97 and I struck him out four
times in the game and after the game
someone that said something to him about
you know what did you have to think
about showing you said you need to go
talk to somebody to actually saw the
ball today was kind of funny and then
the next year he took me deep the right
field in Philly and then the other one
was I believe a ball to right field in
in Yankee Stadium the cheapy you never
faced Ortiz I know no I didn't I didn't
if you had what would have been the
scouting report you know what it all
depends and everybody asked questions
like this it always depends on where
like David Ortiz with Manny Ramirez was
a very different David Ortiz
David Oteri's with Mookie Betts hitting
behind him is it all depends on
situations but I know this I would I
don't I don't think I had very many I
might have had I think less than ten
intentional walks in my career because I
hated that to me that was just like the
epitome of admitting someone's better
than you and I didn't like that but
facing David Ortiz in a game of the
ninth inning he might be a guy I put
four on
just because I wanted guys to to make
mistakes in late in the game and they
did a lot because of the pressure David
and Derrick didn't David and Derrick
didn't and the difference for me always
was Derrick is single and and and all
that David didn't make soft contact
after the 7th inning and that was that's
a difference so I you know and if you
the thing that Marvel's has always
marveled me about David is his ability
to hit the ball in the inner half of the
plate as big as he is if you look at a
lot of the balls he drives out of the
ballpark on the ball they he loves that
ball in and that was always where I
that's why I wonder I'm going to guess
Mariano had Mulkey a good career because
everybody but I'm gonna guess Mariano I
had pretty good numbers about against
David because he could make the ball run
in on David and David liked the ball in
I I couldn't do that so I had to make
David chase and David didn't do a lot of
chasing the the more experience he got
would you vote for you for the whole
thing
no why because I'll play the game I
always play with people that ask me that
question I'm gonna ask you I'm gonna
name a name and you tell me Hall of Fame
or not ok ok Barry Bonds yes ok
they just say just say yes or no Derek
Jeter yes
ken griffey jr. yeah Mike Mussina no huh
no ok any time you have to hesitate it's
a no yeah right and to me now the Hall
of Fame doesn't have that criteria right
because they clearly it's it's a there
are a lot of there there are Dale Murphy
should be in the Hall of Fame Dale
Murphy was the best player in the
eighties I think Fred McGriff should be
in the Hall of Fame but but character
counts for far less which is like I like
the el murfi clearly isn't he should be
in the Hall saying first ballot but I
always looked at it is like ok Randy
Johnson yes or no yes like funny right
Pedro yes
ok you know when you don't have to think
it's in lock that's it that's a guy that
gets a black and so in my Hall of Fame
it would be oh my god there's no doubt
this guy deserves to be in the Hall of
Fame and you can go in the Hall of Fame
and listen I don't want to diminish the
honor because it's the greatest of the
greatest but at the end and the day
people walk by go out act like people
talked about Bill Mazeroski as you know
apparently defensively he was Roberto
Alomar before there was a Roberto Alomar
yeah well that's not enough for a
homeless Famer I mean II agree in a lot
of ways because and I say you being that
the the the fan and the voter or the
person on the outside looking in the
amount of undervalue people put on
defenses laughable to me as a pitcher
defense was every bit as important not
more important than than batting average
home runs and RBIs so when I look at a
guy like Roberto Alomar I see all of
Fame bat but like a guy that should have
been a hundred percent he was a bit one
probably the best thing for the second
baseman ever lived
yeah Omar Vizquel is a hall-of-famer
absolutely okay
and it has nothing to do with his bat no
no he was a good offensive player and I
think he's a better fielder than Ozzie
Smith do you think it was the best of
all time the best the best I ever played
in front of what was in all five Alex
Gonzalez had the best defensive season a
shortstop I've ever seen in my life and
it's underrated and that to me is a very
like I said Derrick was not a Hall of
Fame defender it was and again I'm
talking about Hall of Fame all-star
greatness he wasn't that guy offensively
and personality wise he was a force and
that's why he's all because a winner but
you know I mean the gold the Gold Glove
thing tends to carry a lot more weight
than it should yeah I think it's
overrated in some instances but uh I
mean Mike Trout is going to be a Hall of
Famer
here's the thing Mike Trout it is okay I
look at Mike Trout and then I look at
the rest of Bay he's so far above every
it's gonna finish in the top I began
this you know and this is gonna be
something people are gonna look back in
seven years and four or five years ago
oh my god like a lot like Adrian Beltre
right I think your belt or Hall of Fame
yes I agree and but you'll have people
that come and you know the everyday
family bit what a gem belt but you look
at the body work and then you realize
defensively he was as good as anybody
ever played the game
okay let me leave you with this if Mike
Trout got hurt right now what he getting
all of him if he was never able to play
again uh I don't think about it
backed him in okay but but we're looking
at JJ Watt whose back is acted up it's
not gonna play again this season and we
wondered he's probably a Hall of Famer
if he doesn't play again
you know Koufax you talked about Gale
Sayers there's guys how about how about
Barry Bonds career ends the day he
starts eating the jalapeno be my problem
with that is that he Hall of Famer
wouldn't cheat you're like no but if you
if you look at Barry Bonds his body of
work and you say that before what was it
somewhere ninety nine in that area yes
you look at his career before that he's
the first man yes he is and if you don't
have McGwire or Sosa Kurt then you don't
have this reincarnation of variable
absolutely all right good agree well I
got a good look at us a green I know
you're voting for Trump absolutely right
there with you I'm gonna be on the front
row next debate Mark Cuban to come back
you better just destroy him
Thank You Kurt the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience